I was in a meeting some months ago.
The New York Historical Society's board
of trustees are Gus wonderful group of
people.
That's about 35 very rich New Yorkers
and two token historians and I'm one of
the token historians.
They have was there for window dressing
and other good and useful and noble
purposes.
And during a discussion of a subject,
I won't even go into one of the
very intelligent and very
dedicated members of that board,
and I'm not being ironic,
said that he really wished American
history could be about people of goodwill.
He wished American history
wasn't so full of conflict
and effect.
He was asking,
why can't we really just tell the
stories about people of goodwill?
And I remember thinking,
Oh dear,
this poor man.
But of course I didn't say anything.
I kept my mouth shut.
I nearly threw up
and I just went home about my business.
But why can't history just
be about people, right?
Goodwill.
I'll leave that to you to figure out.
Sometimes there is a great deal of
goodwill and sometimes there isn't.
A reconstruction is a classic story of,
we've said this already,
great change,
great experimentation,
change forced upon people in some ways
as we'll see where the 14th amendment in
a moment,
and yet I'm enough of a cadre of
leadership accepted that challenge
and rewrote the country you
live in and yet of course
like all great change.
It caused a tremendous,
and I don't know if there's
a Newton's law of history,
an opposite and equal reaction.
Revolutions always caused
counterrevolutions just count on it.
Look throughout American history.
Just for a moment,
let's play some games of historical
cycles just for a moment.
I think of the greatest,
I mean take your pick the greatest
fundamental changes in American history,
whether that's in society,
the law,
no massive immigration, the change,
the demographics of the country.
Take your pick,
but pick three or four of the greatest
moments of change in American history.
Every one of them cars do counter change.
Every revolution we have
causes a counterrevolution.
You grew up reaping the great changes
in the civil rights revolution.
You take them for granted.
We most of us do.
Did you also came of age in the midst
of the counterrevolution against it?
If you experienced the civil war
and reconstruction in America,
you experienced,
or a revolution in many ways,
perhaps even more fundamental than
the one in the sixties and seventies
and you experienced very quickly,
it's counterrevolution.
Okay.
No,
I just want to say that because if the
more you read about reconstruction,
the more it seems to me, you find
serious writers on reconstruction,
historians or otherwise,
and not a lot of popular writers
and journalists who've discovered
reconstruction. We're going to read
a book by one of the Nick Lemann,
who is the dean of the
journalism school at Columbia,
who in quite good ways,
fashions himself and his story.
He always says he's not a real
historian, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
But he did pretty good research
for this book on violence, uh,
largely in Mississippi in 1875 but he's
using it as a window into the counter
revolution your soon to be reading about.
Uh,
but most people who write
about this period now tend
to do it in tones of a kind
of a requiem,
a requiem.
Uh,
a tragic mold,
a mold that that is always saying what
might have been what was attempted,
what was, you know, aim
for but then failed,
fell apart. What high aspiration.
But God, they couldn't quite do it.
And it is a national requiem in a sense.
Somebody should write that symphony,
the reconstruction symphony.
We need a Beethoven for that and he
needs to be really depressed one day.
But that doesn't mean it won't be great
and we won't learn from it. Feel from it
all right back on the ground.
I got in some cheap shots and Andrew
Johnson before we left the other day and
they were that cheap shots.
No apologies.
Um, but Andrew Johnson, the
course of key player here,
he comes to the presidency because he's
only comes running mate and his office
saying he's gonna make trees and odious
and some radical Republicans were quite
fond initially of that approach.
But it quickly, quickly changed.
And here in a nutshell,
you've read this now phoner you've all
gotten up through at least the first four
chapters.
And by the way,
I've now visited at least three sections
and I'm enjoying it. I wish they were.
I wish they weren't just 50 minutes.
You just get going and
of course this just gets going and then
you're glad we're out of here in 15
minutes and I'm sure,
but back to Andrew Johnson,
he was above all else
and Arden states rightest
he did not support succession.
Now you can be a state's rights.
You can believe that power should always
remain in the hands of the state and
still not believe in the right of
succession. And he was one of those.
He believes the session was political
suicide for the south, and Lo and behold,
he got that one right.
He had a strong attachment to the
American Union. He was a unionist
and a Patriot in that sense.
He had a hatred also of the southern
planter class because he didn't grow up in
it. He was a poor boy who made good
and a huge chip on his shoulder.
He was brilliant in a certain, he was
brilliant at a certain kind of politics,
which was east Tennessee stump politics.
Andrew Johnson.
It was said could crawl up on the back
of a wagon and a hold an audience for two
hours in east Tennessee.
He didn't very easily convert that
style and that talent at local stump
politics.
However,
to the much broader world of pragmatic
negotiation of Washington or the
presidency, he'd held every
kind of offers you could hold.
Had been mayor of Greenville,
Tennessee. He'd been in stake,
a senator or a state legislature,
he'd been governor of Tennessee.
He was then elected senator from Tennessee
and then once again appointed the
wartime governor of Tennessee by Abraham
Lincoln. In the midst of the war,
he'd held every level of office,
hey,
never been antislavery.
He saw the end of slavery as
a misfortune for the south,
something that had to be
accepted as a verdict of war.
Okay.
Johnson had one essential slogan for his
approach to reconstruction and if you
can remember that slogan, you and that
in essence have his point of view.
The constitution as it is
and the Union as it was
constitution as it is
in the union as it was,
don't revise the constitution.
He would accept the 13th amendment,
the end of slavery, because of the war
that was part of the verdict of the war.
There wasn't any way around that,
but he never accepted the 14th and 15th
amendments and he worked vehemently to
destroy the 14th amen.
Yeah.
Or at least he worked VM and lead
to urge states not to ratify it.
No.
His approach to reconstruction and
once in office was essentially this.
He took Lincoln's lenient plan,
the 10% plan,
anyone another step further
in its leniency or some
say several steps further.
Instead of saying he wanted 10% of the
voting population of a confederate state
to take loyalty, almost form of
government come back and so forth.
He simply converted 10% to quote
that portion who are loyal.
Any portion,
wherever maybe two or more are gathered.
We'll have a loyal government,
that portion who are loyal.
No,
he added one exception to the pardons.
However you remember people
were going to get pardoned. Um,
lieutenant and above and so forth.
I mean it lieutenant and below
in the confederate forces,
he had a one exception to the pardons
and this reflected a very personal
interest of his.
He would not pardon?
He said at first at least any southerner
who owned $20,000 worth of property or
more,
it seemed like a class appeal.
Nobody owned $20,000 at the planter class.
In other words,
was not going to get a pardon no
matter what they did during the war.
If they were rich, they weren't
going to be pardoned. Well,
at least until they applied for it and
the application had to be personal to the
president of the United States.
Now this set in motion and
80 65 a bizarre process.
Um,
he promised clemency but only after they
made formal written applications about
their new loyalty and what literally
occurred by the end of 1865 and then,
especially in the first months of 1866,
his lines formed at the White
House in Washington. Often women,
southern women came to Wa lines out doors
on a daily basis at times with their
written applications for clemency
and pardon for participation in the
confederate war effort.
Yeah.
After one year of this process,
by May,
1866 Johnson himself at personally
signed 7,000 such pardons,
he wanted to make them grovel.
In other words,
yeah,
no,
why is policy but a policy nonetheless,
he did put in place or trieds, uh,
some so called Johnson governments.
Now instead of calling
them Lincoln governments,
they would be called Johnson Garmins.
And the reason John's going to get a
hold of and get away with this of course,
is you should know from reading,
is that Congress went out of session
in the summer of 1865 for a month.
I went on a session and Johnson
had largely a free hand to act.
And did he ever,
by December of 65,
one a new congress would
reconvene in Washington.
Okay.
All the states and the former confederacy,
except Texas had met the
simplest of criteria,
had written new state constitutions,
had found that portion who are
loyal to form a new government,
and it was very tiny proportions
in some places. In fact,
there were no loyalty oath,
even even applied to
people all but one state,
Texas was ready for
readmission to the union.
Okay,
under this, uh, what actually phone
calls it in his book, the amazing quote,
amazing leniency of Andrew Johnson.
Okay.
The only major demand put upon them
was to formerly nullify their active
succession.
That's basically all they had to do.
Now these were whites only governments.
These are governments formed by former
confederates and in many of these states,
of course, they began to rapidly
in the late summer or early fall,
1865 pass. What became quickly
known as the black codes.
You've actually got a portion of the
Virginia Black codes in the gap reader.
I had three or four of those
laws are there in your reader,
read them with some care.
These black codes mirrored
the old slave codes.
They explicitly denied the right to vote
to blacks, the right to serve on juries,
right to hold office,
the right to own property.
There were all kinds of restrictive,
uh,
vagrancy laws pass pass laws passed where
blacks could be at any given point in
time with,
with or without a pass.
And in this newly reconstructed
Johnson approach to these states,
there was a great deal of legislation
already flowing from some of these new
state legislatures meant to
directly obstruct the work
of the Freedmen's bureau.
The counterrevolution folks began
almost as soon as the war was over.
As soon as x, confederates
could find their way into power.
And did they ever
part of what went on here,
the northern mine,
now that's remember the blood of the wars,
not entirely dry,
but part of what was just simply going
on here on the northern mine is they
witnessed this.
And as these new states now sent their
representatives and senators after fall
election back to Washington,
some of them literally wearing
their confederate uniforms
and from Georgia came no less than as
the new US senator from Georgia Alexander
Age Stephens year ago, he was the vice
president of the confederacy. Well,
it's been six months in a Charles
town jail in Massachusetts,
allegedly arrested for his
treason against the United States,
but it released
and as they began to arrive in Washington,
it was this kind of
insolence on the part of x.
Confederates did in some ways began
to stimulate what we will call radical
reconstruction.
Radical reconstruction is a plan,
and if owners are right on
that, he said, you know,
one of the reasons the this cadre of
Republicans succeeded is because they
really did have a plan.
If there's a revolution going on and
something's got to be redone about your
country, go to the
meeting with a plan. Uh,
James Madison did that by the way,
at their original drafting
of the constitution,
and you've got most of what he took,
but they came back to Washington with
x confederate generals, colonels,
members of that,
members of the confederate cabinet and
the vice president of the confederacy.
Jeff Davis couldn't get
elected in Mississippi yet
because Jeff Davis was still
the only x confederate still in jail.
He will never be formally indicted.
He spent two years at fortress
Monroe in a prison in Virginia.
Tremendous mythology has grown around
that story that he wasn't fed properly,
that he was mistreated,
that he got ill and wasn't giving medical
attention virtually all of which is
nonsense. He didn't, he
wasn't terribly well at times,
but it wasn't because he
didn't get medical attention.
By the time the United States government
under the Johnson administration,
in fact, Johnson wanted absolutely
nothing to do with trying Jefferson Davis.
But by the time they even got around
to finally formally considering it,
they had wasted so much time.
The Jefferson Davis will
finally be formally released,
uh, in the spring, April
to be exact of 1867,
two years after his arrest.
And just to show you the harbingers of
reconciliation and the political culture,
the people who paid his bail,
we're all northerners,
some of them quite famous
Horace Greeley of the new day,
the great editor of The New York
Herald Tribune, and the abolitionist,
although a strange and mercurial character
by now put up the most amount and
none other than Garret Smith,
the former radical abolitionist
from upstate New York,
who checked himself into an insane asylum
after John Brown's raid paid most of
the rest of the Bale
and Jefferson Davis
would be released April,
1867 to a cheering crowd in Richmond,
Virginia.
He would go on to write,
to live in the south of course,
and to write the longest,
most Turgid,
most overblown personal memoir about
a failed political movement in all of
history,
about 1300 page memoir.
Basically all arguing succession was
right in the war, wasn't about slavery,
uh,
enough on Davis for the moment.
But back to Washington when this,
when this,
these new state governments send their
representatives to Congress beginning of
December, that's a congress with
the obvious Republican majority
and they absolutely called
a halt to the whole process.
Here were all these people from
the south coming to take the Lord.
They're not loyalty oath,
but the old of office into the u s
congress and they were stopped at some of
them physically at the door and told
to go home and the Republican Party now
began to try to rest control and they
did wrest control of reconstruction away
from Andrew Johnson.
And from that day forward,
you had the beginnings
of a growing titanic,
constitutional political struggle
between president and Congress.
They are not of the same party to say
the least that will result in Andrew
Johnson's impeachment
now to the radicals for a moment.
They established what was known as
the joint committee on reconstruction.
They're never been such a committee really
in American history before that date.
This was to be a committee of
members of both houses of Congress,
but they made no pretense to
bipartisanship. It had 15 members,
12 of whom are Republicans and three
Democrats. They said, thank you very much.
We don't need anymore.
Now they established this joint committee.
It began to meet in January of
[inaudible] 66 the purpose of which was to
investigate what was going on on the
ground in the south to investigate the
necessities and needs of reconstruction
to investigate the further needs of the
Freedmen's bureau and to recommend to
Congress what legislation ought be passed
to reconstruct the country.
They held massive hearings,
the largest such congressional hearings
in American history to that time,
they saw 144 witnesses
over about two months,
including Robert E. Lee himself, who
came up from Richmond to testify,
testifying essentially under orders,
and he's still was under house arrest.
He didn't really have a choice.
They ask hundreds of questions,
but you can boil them down to these.
They asked about the treatment of Friedman
in the south and their witnesses were
all kinds of people, union
officers, Freedmen's bureau agents,
some white southerners for
sure, some famous, most not.
They ask lots of questions about the
levels of Lolo, t and disloyalty.
What were the political
attitudes of southerners?
They were really trying to find out what
would white south, southern is actually,
do you know if we did that?
Now this is absolutely
crucial because we've long,
I wouldn't say assumed what we've long
wondered and there's a lot of evidence
for this that had the white
south in its prostate state,
in its state of destruction and defeat.
How'd they truly been put
under an honest to God,
legitimate near total occupation.
The assumption is among a lot of scholars
that they being the white south would
have accepted it because
they didn't have any choice.
They had virtually no choice at all and
some of their leadership was already in
exile.
I think I mentioned the other day about
eight to 10,000 x confederate leaders,
mostly military people had left
the country at least temporarily.
Anyway, they're trying to test a
what southern attitudes or thirdly,
they ask lots of questions about
the needs of the Freedmen's bureau,
what authors bureau do, what
about schools, what about
food, what about hospitals,
et Cetera.
And then they would ask about the need
for troops and the need for enforcement.
Now you may know from reading phone or
by now that the reduction in in the union
armies was overnight from
nearly a million men in arms
to a mere 15 to 20,000 by 1866
yeah,
and a fair portion of those are
being sent west to fight Indians
and one of the great deep myths about
the melodrama reconstruction or the loss
cause version of reconstruction over the
years is that the south was put under
this military occupation bayonet
rule as it so often was called
about the only time a union
soldier fixed the bay in it,
in all the reconstruction years was when
they put their band at on and parked to
defend themselves and go after the
people who were murdering and massacring
black people in Memphis
and New Orleans in 1866
the vast majority of union troops
throughout the reconstruction years in the
south.
We're simply in garrison forts on the
coastlines occasionally in the cities.
The conclusions of this report,
which was by the joint committees report,
which by the way chaired by
William Pitt Fessenden of Maine,
a moderate Republican senator, but a
key figure. He had a lot of prestige.
He'd been in the U S Senate forever.
He was an old time Republican,
but a moderate who had come to
see the verdict of the civil war,
the destruction of slavery and
the challenge to make it good.
Their conclusions were essentially this,
and they actually use this word that
it would be quote madness to let x
confederates run the new southern
state governments madness
was the word used by the
committee's report. Secondly,
the Johnson's style of leniency
towards reconstruction,
and they had various
ways of putting this in.
Ferris conclusions I draw
from this was foolish
and the third,
and last but not least,
they made a whole series
of recommendations for what
they call safe guards that
would be necessary
to guarantee security in the
south and the beginnings,
at least of a new political
regime in every state.
Now,
it is that Republican majority
congress of the winter,
Spring and summer of 1866 that
began to first pass the great,
the great legislation of reconstruction
and if you want to see reconstruction as
this rise and fall requiem and why not?
This is the rise.
If reconstruction was a kind of bright
shining moment as dubois once called it
and black reconstruction in
1935 this was its moment,
1866 and 67 when the actual system
by which the southern states would be
readmitted to the union was put in place.
The first thing they passed was the civil
rights act of 1866 passed congress in
April of 66.
This was an act of Congress
now constitutional amendment
and therefore it didn't
require two thirds.
It was the first statutory definition
and American history of the rights of
citizenship.
It was potentially a profound
change in federal state relations.
This Republican Congress
and it's leadership,
at least it was going to do some very
new things with American federalism.
Now
it had a bunch of flaws.
Um,
it gave full citizenship to all
Americans regardless of race, creed,
or color. It's said that the
first time ever in our history,
we'd never had a citizenship law.
It had never been legally
determined who was a US citizen,
but citizenship had always
implied whiteness and maleness.
It now had at least the definition,
the problem in and of course its flaw
and there'll be a flaw and a compromise
and element and almost everything past
in these years, nothing came up pure.
Out of these terrible
debates over reconstruction.
It's great flaw was that it was directed
against public but not private acts of
discrimination.
I might still discriminate, again,
discriminated against you in any way,
a wish privately with my business,
with my private facility,
with my school,
with a lot of ways,
but in terms of public civic rights,
it at least put in place the beginnings
of the idea of citizenship rights.
Secondly, this Congress
renewed the Freedmen's bureau.
I gave it a new life for another year
and they did this and the civil rights
act,
by the way,
over the rapid and quick
veto of Andrew Johnson,
what's set in as early as April of 1866
was the federal government by veto,
Congress would pass a law. Well this
is the Civil Rights Act, the renewal,
the Freedmen's bureau and
numerous other things.
Eventually all four of the reconstruction
and acts in early 67 and Johnson would
veto them.
Andrew Johnson in one in one and a half
years we'll issue more presidential
vetoes and all American presidents
before him put together.
Okay.
Not the weather thing supposed to work,
but that's the way this was working.
And then for six months
the congress debated and let's remember,
there's still about a one third of
this congress that are Democrat.
Yes.
I don't know how close I can get you
to this and I want to try at least to
section one.
Oh dear. I don't know. Can you read
that? Good. Cause that's
the country you live in.
Oh, I'm sounding so pretentious
today. But you know what?
United States was invented at
Philadelphia in 1787 but in many ways,
and Americans still don't get this.
Don't understand it, don't know it.
The country you actually live in
was invented in 1866 in Washington.
D C is the country of the 14th amendment.
The 14th amendment has five parts.
It's the first one, the new one,
the one authored by John Bingham,
staunch Christian abolitionist from
Ohio into a tiny little college called
Franklin College.
It is that first clause that
actually revolutionized,
if you want the revolution,
the 14th amendment was,
wasn't effect the Republican
leadership's response to emancipation.
Yeah,
well of course the 13th amendment is too,
but the 13th amendment you'll remember,
has a second clause and said Congress
shall pass all appropriate legislation to
enforce it. All right. Now how do
you enforce the end of slavery?
Was the end of slavery are to mean,
or as you were discussing in sections
yesterday in his phone or his chapter
addresses,
what did freedom mean?
What the amendment did,
is it enshrined birthright in the shrine?
At least two things into the constitution.
Even though they're ill defined at
first and we're still fighting over them
right now and probably two thirds of the
courts in the United States as we speak,
and by the way about two
thirds of everything and an
American case law book is a
14th amendment case. Those gigantic,
Godawful, thick case law books,
if you ever opened one,
about two thirds of everything in
there goes through the 14th amendment.
Anyway,
it didn't shrine birthright
citizenship number one and number two,
the beginnings of the idea of equal rights
under the constitution
took six months of debate.
It was passed finally in June of 1866
these were the new framers
if you want the new founders,
it's the first set of
challenges they faced.
Um, they've settled pretty, not easily,
but they pretty much settled
in clean and clear language.
Those first three challenges were number
one to define citizenship and who holds
it. Now the rights act had
already begun to do that.
This is going to go a little further too.
They had the problem of repudiating
confederate award dense. What do you do?
All those debts that a confederate state
at entail toward Great Britain or Spain
or France or anyone else.
The federal government was here by saying
in a constitutional amendment that any
debt the confederacy had entailed to any
government, any people, any bank, anybody,
anywhere that the you would United States,
federal government would never pay them,
but they were also here trying to
head off of course the demands for
compensation, for loss of slave
property as a confederate debt
and three they had to face the question
now that every reconstruction plan had
to face and then in Lincoln had it in
his and Johnson had it and even the way
Davis Bill had it and that
is which x confederates are
going to get disqualified,
disqualified or disfranchised.
How many x confederates,
what level of disfranchisement would
there be from office holding or for that
matter citizenship rights at all?
Rex Confederates,
these three,
they settled but there were three others.
They did not settle so easily
and they were the extent of the
right to vote for black men would,
would this amendment declare the right
to vote for black men everywhere are only
in the south,
only in confederate states.
The inconvenient and terrible
problem on this one of course,
is that the very men writing this bill,
uh,
no,
that in their own northern states,
black suffrage is not
popular to say the least.
And most northern whites still
don't want black men to vote,
especially in their own states.
The evidence of that was so clear.
The state of Connecticut,
this state in 1865 after the war was over,
held a special referendum
and overwhelmingly voted
down the right to vote for
black men in Connecticut.
Secondly,
they had to settle the extent of civil
rights declared equal before the law.
How equal which rights were
okay
at First Section of the 14th amendment
ends with the famous language of equal
protection of the laws.
No one shall be deprived.
There's no state shall deprive
any person of life, liberty,
or property without due process nor deny
any person within his jurisdiction the
equal protection of the law.
And then the lastly,
they faced the vexing problem.
Now, and you may have forgotten all
about this, it's easy to forget it.
How to reapportion representation
of the so called slave seats.
Those are the extra congressmen that
southern states had been given from the
1790s on through 1860 because of the
three fifths clause in the constitution.
The estimate is that between 1,818
60 the slave states in the south,
depending on when you take the snapshot
received from 20 to 30 additional
congressmen in the house because
of the three fifths clause,
because three fifths of black people
were being counted for representation.
Okay?
Now what happens is you're
gonna count all black people.
Yeah.
The estimate was that the south southern
states would get an additional 18 more
congressman.
So when these new states
come back into the union,
they're going to have more
congressman, more power, more cloud.
When are you gonna do with that?
No,
the key players in this,
and I want to spend through this as quick
as possible, the key players in this,
we're on the one hand,
Thaddeus Stevens as a kind of
visionary in radical voice.
Stephen's would have had this
amendment go further than it did,
especially on black suffrage.
Probably its greatest architect of two
of them really were John Bingham of Ohio
and Lyman Trumbull of Illinois.
They're unsung heroes. Yeah,
I bet you don't know anything about
John Bingham and probably nothing about
Lyman Trumbull. Um, they're not famous.
They should be
Bingham road.
Section one Wyman.
Trumbull wrote the 64 civil
rights at 66 civil rights sac.
He actually wrote the 13th amendment
and he will write other parts of the
reconstruction legislation.
John Bingham,
we'll stand up day after day in the
congress and we'll argue that emancipation
had finally forced the United States.
This is the way he always put it to apply
the bill of rights to everybody and he
argued in his words that
what they were really doing.
Now we're federalizing the bill of rights.
Now think about it,
American history,
it always had the bill of rights.
Just tick them off the first 10
amendments to the constitution,
you're right to religion and your
right to free speech and your right to
assembly and on and on and on.
But it had never been
applied to all Americans.
They've never even been an assumption
that applied to all Americans.
Okay.
Well, um, there were others,
Charles, to some extent,
Robert Dale, Owen of Indiana,
the old utopian community leader.
I was quite a visionary of this as well.
Um,
and some others,
but it's really a handful of six or seven
people who wrote the 14th amendment.
Now they faced tremendous
opposition day in and day out.
Democrats would get up and say though,
all the 14th amendment really was trying
to do is to get white and black people
to marry each other.
They tried it out,
the worst of white supremacy and the
worst of racism to try to trash the vision
of the 14th amendment.
It's going to have effect eventually
in a larger American politics.
Rest assured because the 68 presidential
election is going to be a referendum on
this and it will be without question the
most white supremacist racist election
and all of American history.
Yeah,
so unsettled and so blunt
that it will surprise you.
I suspect the central compromise
in the 14th amendment,
I'll let you read the
rest of its provisions,
but the central compromise was actually
on black suffrage. As I said, there was,
is uncomparable fact that most white
northerners didn't want black people to
vote in the north,
so they left any enforcement of
the right to vote to the states.
Okay.
Now going to codify the right devote
for black males and by the way,
it's the first time the word male
got into the u s constitution.
Very complicated important amendment
and it's going to cause it terrible
explosion.
Actually a bad train wreck between the
women's suffrage movement and the old
abolition movement,
black and white men.
It's going to cause Elizabeth
Cady Stanton and Susan B.
Anthony and others to basically bolt
from the black suffrage movement and even
the whole civil rights movement such
as it was during reconstruction.
And go off and fight their own crusade.
That's another long story we'll return to.
So instead of an outright guarantee of
the right to vote everywhere for blacks,
men, the final version left
control of suffrage to the states.
It did though in one provision,
penalize if a state to
come back into the union,
denied the right to vote to black men,
it would have its representation in
Congress reduced to the proportion of the
black males in their
state. Oh, that's fine.
I'm going to scare many northern states
cause they don't have large black
populations.
Okay.
And actually they're not going to be
part of that provision because they never
seceded from the union.
But the key thing here is
that the equality, Jeanie,
this language of equal protection,
this definition of citizenship rights,
it never happened before. The equality
Jeannie was now out of the bottle.
And for better or worse,
it could never be put back.
The equal protection clause is the most
malleable provision in the constitution.
It has been used,
uh,
to support or advance the rights
of everyone and everything,
every kind of organization you can
imagine. Cities, states, corporations,
immigrants, women, gays and lesbians,
Anti Gay and lesbian movements, students,
labor unions,
anti labor union movements.
It has advanced tolerance and intolerance
and has advanced affirmative action.
And the anti affirmative action crusade,
the 14th amendment is so mainly
bullet can be used by anyone.
It's the great legal wellspring of
was in modern civil rights revolution.
No 14th amendment,
no civil rights movement.
And last but not least,
it is the basis of that dreadful supreme
court decision in 2000 known as Bush v
Gore.
I didn't make that up.
Now
in this circumstance for the passage
of the civil rights act passage,
new Freedmen's bureau passage of the
14th amendment not to be sent out to the
states for ratification comes the fall
elections of 1866 and Andrew Johnson took
his case out on the road.
Um,
he called it the swing around the circle.
The circle was to be the union,
or where's my map?
I have a better map here.
Oops.
Well, I don't even really have the
whole north on here. Sorry about that.
Oh,
well
in the fall elections of 1866
these were congressional elections,
but the terribly important given
what's going on in Congress,
the 66 congressional elections were a
referendum on reconstruction and they came
in the wake of two terrible racial
riots or massacres in south,
which really got northern attention.
The first was in New Orleans,
the other in Memphis.
In both cases they were essentially
police riots in Memphis.
About 40 blacks were killed and over
200 whole neighborhoods is destroyed.
Okay.
Congressional investigations
launched in New Orleans.
The riots or massacre that was conducted
by the white police of New Orleans
against its black community,
was stimulated by a political
parade of black Republicans.
In the late spring 1866 before the New
Orleans riot was over 34 blacks were
killed,
about 250 wounded and
hundreds of homes destroyed.
This was the state of chaos and reaction
already going on in the south and you
don't even really have legitimate
functioning governments yet.
So out on the hustings that fall,
the campaign appeals were on the one
hand by Democrats to prejudice and racism
and leave the south alone.
Democrats are out on the hustings blaming
Republicans for causing that violence
in the south. If you give
black people the right to vote,
if you will let black people
move too high, too far, too
fast, et Cetera, et Cetera,
et cetera.
And the Republicans attacking
Andrew Johnson for everything,
including his drunkenness
at his inauguration,
but most importantly for his insolence
and obstinance and obstruction to
reconstruction.
So Johnson took his case to the people.
He went on a long tour,
he called it the swing around the circle,
all over the northern states, up through
New England, all across the Midwest.
And he tried to be the old stump speaker
from east Tennessee and it totally
backfired on him.
He demanded that Ulysses
grant go with him.
He demanded the William h Seward
go with him, secretary of State,
and they reluctantly joined them. They
were after all serving him as president.
Grant Heda. This granted
into like politics. He soon.
Now I have to change his tune on that.
But what happened in in essence is it
Andrew Johnson went out and caused a
gigantic embarrassment for himself,
for grant and for others.
He took out hundreds and hundreds of new
US flags that had 36 stars and not the
okay.
Without the s the 11 secede as the states
and he would pass out the flags and
everywhere he went, he would make the
same speech over and over and over.
He would say, you would always begin
by saying, I stand on the constitution.
And then he started talking
about the traders in Congress.
He called them traitors.
Stephen's in Sumner,
in Bingham and Fessenden
in their own states.
No one,
very clever.
He even engage in all kinds of on
dignified displays and certain kinds of
vulgarity.
Crowds began to react to them.
He gives the same damn speech town
after town, after town, after town.
It'd be reprinted in the paper and
before he could get up and say,
I stand on the constitution, and the crowd
would start saying, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're standing in the
constitution. Crowds started
shouting back at him saying,
shut up and stop,
and we'd rather hear grant
and chance of that sort.
It became in some instances,
by the time he got to the
Midwest and Indiana and Illinois,
impossible for him even
to hold an audience.
Then finally he started to compare
himself to Jesus on the cross.
Never a good idea.
He was being crucified by the radical
traders wing of the Republican Party and
Congress.
And then he invented a story that he had
been the one called Judas and he worked
at, you, worked at Judas Metaphor
about as often as he could.
He was finally shouted off
the stage and Pittsburgh
and he just took the train and went home
and he also kept referring to
this magical circle of the union,
magical circle of the union.
And it became a parody.
And in the fall elections,
the people of the northern states return
an overwhelming majority of Republicans
to the congress,
a slightly more than two thirds
veto proof majority to the congress.
And it will be that Congress once it
convenes in December 66 and then the next
winter of [inaudible] 67 that we'll put
in place the first reconstruction act
and then three consecutive
three subsequent reconstruction
acts to enforce the
first and that first reconstruction act.
We will come back to next
time cause it's crucial,
but it's set up here and
you can see it on this map.
A system by which the south was to now
be divided into five military districts,
two or three states in each,
the x confederacy divided into five
military districts each commanded by major
general.
That major general was to have control
over elections and electoral boards and a
sufficient body of troops.
It's said to enforce the electoral
process in the south and there was to be,
according to that first
reconstruction act as we'll see,
a high level of confederate.
This now will be the Republican Party
taking control of reconstruction
of trying to plant the Republican party
into the south now with African American
votes.
Okay.
And they will succeed
in creating Republican
control legislatures,
governors offices in all 11
of the x confederate states,
at least at first and in some of
those states will see some remarkable
experimental democracy put in place
on precedent to that time in American
history. Unfortunately, of course,
what will also be stimulated and put in
place is a deeply embittered reaction
and the white south to now do whatever
it took by any means necessary to destroy
the Republican Party,
to destroy African-american autonomy,
to destroy the African
American right to vote.
And it will be organizations like the Ku
Klux Klan that had been around at least
since 1866 but are going to explode with
fury in 1868 and between 1868 and 1871
the Klan and its many,
many, many imitators.
We'll engage in a kind of violence as
real politics to try to take back control
of the political south.
And I'll leave you there hanging
with goodwill.